today finally a team of 14 nuclear
safety inspectors arrived at ukraine's
zaparizia nuclear power plant
it took weeks to negotiate safe passage
for the team and their arrival is not a
minute too soon
there have been several potentially
catastrophic failures at the plant in
recent weeks which ukrainian and russian
forces are blaming on each other the
inspectors have their work cut out for
them to safeguard europe's largest
nuclear power plant that happens to be
in the middle of a war zone we have this
report
experts from the international atomic
energy agency being shown around the
zaparisia nuclear power plant by russian
energy officials
on thursday they made a first tour of
the key areas they wanted to see
with ukraine and russia blaming each
other for shelling near the facility the
agency's head said the physical
integrity of the plant had been violated
and he emphasized that their mission is
far from over
we are not going anywhere the iaea is
now there is at the plant and it's not
moving it's going to stay there we're
going to have a continued presence there
at the plant with some of my experts
the head of the power company that runs
the plant said they are working to
restart the reactor and expressed hope
that the un mission could help
we believe it would be
like
main purpose of this mission for us just
to demilitarize
the territory of the paris nuclear power
plant and surrounding area if this
mission helps to do that then it will be
successful
in the short term the iaea plans to keep
a group of experts at the plant for the
next several days to continue their
assessment of the damage already done to
the facility a dangerous unprecedented
mission in the midst of a war zone
well my first guest tonight has worked
as a safety inspector at nuclear power
plants around the world including at
chernobyl and fukushima he's also been
an advisor in science and technology to
the u.s state department mr najmadeen
mishkati is an engineering professor at
the university of southern california
he joins me tonight from california
professor it's good to have you on the
program
i'd like for us to start by listening to
what the head of the iaea said today
after he and his team had made their
first walk through at the zaparizia
plant in ukraine take a listen
i worry i worried i worry and i will
continue to be worried about the plant
until we have a situation which is more
stable which is more predictable it is
obvious that that the plant
and the physical integrity of the plant
has been violated several times by
chance by by
deliberation
so he sounds professor
like he is worried he has reason to be
worried when he says the physical
integrity of the plant has been
violated
how serious is that what do you hear in
those words
thank you for having me first of all i
would like really to salute and commend
director general mariano rafael mariano
grossi and iaea team for taking this
doing this mission at personal risk to
their safety they are heroes i think
what the director general said is about
reading between the lines he talked
about the physical infrastructure some
of them because they had if you remember
loss of
offsite power
for a few hours last week and
that plant has been under shelling what
i didn't hear from him in this clip that
you broadcast said is the state of the
mind of the operators and the safety
culture and human performance
due to duress stress and they're
basically working at the gunpowder and i
am extremely worried
as director general said about the
safety of these plans
well professor
based on what we do know about the
situation inside the plant i mean we've
been told that you have ukrainian
workers who are carrying out their jobs
at gunpoint by
russian forces so when you hear that
how concerned are you
that we could have an accident at this
nuclear power plant
an accident that would happen by
human error
that's a very good question that's
precisely my worry because if you look
at the three major nuclear power plant
accidents in our history three mile
island in united states 1979
chernobyl in former soviet union ukraine
1986 and fukushima 2011 in japan both
two out of the three of these nuclear
accidents that caused some major
disruption never caused by internal
factors not external factors by internal
factors i mean human performance safety
culture related issues and human error
and this condition that these operators
have been subject to that since march
2nd of the russian invasion is very dire
and that increases the human error
probability by many faults fatigue
stress
and then uncertainty plus that
all the nine traits of healthy safety
cultures unfortunately have been
violated like the
questioning attitude
environment for
respectful work environment all of these
have been violated by this invasion
and if i hear you correctly professor it
is true we've had two nuclear disasters
in the world the results of of human
error and then in fukushima what we saw
was an earthquake and then a tsunami a
natural disaster causing then a nuclear
disaster
with the ukraine situations apparition
we could have a situation where the
workers make a mistake but for the first
time in history we all have also have
the situation
that missiles are shelling
outside
could penetrate
the the walls of a reactor for example
and cause a meltdown this is a first
isn't it there's not a guidebook for
what inspectors are supposed to do is
there
absolutely you're absolutely right this
is the added value we have this external
risk because of a shelling the shelling
the the
containment dome of the six reactors may
protect them against the internal
reactors sitting in the containment of
they may be protected by the contaminant
but we have huge
six
spent fuel too
that they require constant circulation
and they are not protected by
containment
and then
on the other side the people i i always
considered
human operators of nuclear plant as the
first and last yeller of the last layer
of defense of humanity
these people are subject tremendous
stress
very awful working condition and their
families in the city of
are under tremendous stress and i really
don't know the state of the mind of
these people and i hope director general
grossi and his team they can get to that
professor before we run out of time
you know these inspectors they have
the weight that their own lives are on
the line right now plus the lives of
millions of other people are at stake
right now what would be your message to
them
i asked i wish them god's speed
due diligence in their work i'm sure
that they do however we may be asking
too much from international atomic
energy agency which is score is a
technical organization the report that
they will be issuing is going to be
technical but it will be many layers of
political uh things attached to them i
wish them god's speed i'm sure they do a
due diligence but on the other hand i
think what we need is a little bit above
and beyond international atomic energy
agency which is in the domain of u.n
security council
professor najmadeen mishkani we
appreciate your time and your valuable
insights tonight thank you
all right we want to pull in now vadim
chumachi is head of the laboratory at
ukraine's national research center for
radiation medicine it's good to have you
with us tell me what should these
inspectors be doing right now what
what's the first
duty for these inspectors
uh good evening i'm not familiar with
their particular plan but i can estimate
the possible actions of them
so first of all they need to inspect the
technical condition of the nuclear power
plant in general
and most important
technical condition of the radioactive
materials there
i mean fuel assemblies both
spent fuel and fresh fuel
uh because they're
post
some some danger or i would say
and it's very important that also they
uh relieve some psychological pressure
on the personnel of the nuclear power
plant because they have working for
almost six months
under uh
gunpoint from russian forces
which is also not
in favor of security
well mr trump you know you bring up a
good point um the the employees of the
plant have been under tremendous
pressure these inspectors they're also
under pressure now right because they
perhaps are the only thing that stands
between
millions and millions of lives and a
radioactive meltdown
exactly they're brave people i really
appreciate their their courage and their
uh motivation
to go there because i know from the
reports that it was not easy way today
to get to the nuclear power plant
indeed
we know that um iodine tablets have been
distributed across that part of ukraine
what is your biggest concern right now i
mean what what would be the most acute
danger in your opinion
actually this
potassium iodine
pellets pay pills are
good for extreme scenario
which is could be much like fukushima
scenario
when
electric supply for the pumps which are
cooling the rippers stops
the core starts to melt down then
some hydrogen or
chemical explosion and then release to
the atmosphere and since
at least two reactors are still
operating uh they contain a lot of
various redneck lights including iodine
and iodine has a peculiarity that
it is very uh biologically accessible
and very mobile so it once it is
released
it can easily very easily get through
the organism of of people and then there
it is uh has a property of accumulation
in a thyroid gland
which
creates
might create high doses and this iodine
pills
they uh
block
uh thyroid and prevent from this uh
intake and accumulation mr this is a
really important case scenario it's not
i don't believe it's very large well we
certainly hope
that the worst case scenario will not
become true but in the event of a
radiation leak even if we were to have a
meltdown in your opinion is the medical
infrastructure already in place around
zaparizia around that entire part of
ukraine to deal with mass exposure to
radiation
it's a very good question so actually
we are considering such scenario for
quite a while and
for instance you mentioned this
pills they're already distributed and
they are
will be available once they are needed
but the problem is that
you know the distribution of reactive
materials depends on on wind and
atmospheric conditions and if wind blows
to
eastern direction to the territories
which are occupied by invaders
uh ukraine doesn't have control it
cannot help population so that's the
main problem
vadim chumach head of the laboratory at
ukraine's national research center for
radiation
medicine mr trump we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you